best meme of 2022. why you asking
because I was like trying to I was
trying to ask the mean man yeah yeah can
you remember like what memes were big
this year because I'm trying to think
okay what's what's like some big events
that happened this year I don't know why
like the I don't know it's it's it feels
sad to me like it feels genuinely sad
that I remembered the Will Smith's the
Will Smith slap before some of the more
political things that happened this year
like yeah yeah uh yeah [ __ ] oh that was
this year wasn't it [ __ ]
[Music]
this has just been like a mess of a
[ __ ] year do you reflect a lot in the
year normally or are you more of uh
let's get on the next year ah yeah I I
normally reflect on like at the end of
every year normally on like in in that
period in December where you're just
like oh what did I do this year oh that
was really really cool now how do I
one-up it next year and you're like [ __ ]
I did a lot this year how do I what up
it next year are you are you the kind of
person to set yourself like New Year's
resolutions or are you just kind of like
uh no whatever happens I think we talked
about this last yeah I can't remember
what our last Year's resolutions were uh
sorry for the better I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna hope that we are we we did it
I hope so yeah do you have any
resolutions this year let's let's not
call it resolutions do you have any
goals for next year goals yeah
that's hard enough right
[Music]
going more saunas yeah more money more
more saunas yes more ski trips I want to
be more active next year I think like
physically you said this long I remember
yeah saying this last year I think I
think I was I think this year if there
was a resolution I said that I actually
fulfilled this year compared to last
year is that I have definitely become
more physically active this year yeah
but I feel like we can go further Beyond
you know like I feel like what do you
mean like how what was the difference
between like last year and this year
then okay well last year I wouldn't get
up off my ass at all like zero percent
uh active I didn't I wasn't at the going
to the gym which I am now yeah uh you
know I wasn't doing any like physical
like sport I wasn't going out and like
just [ __ ] touching grass and doing
[ __ ] yeah this year you know I like at
least like once or twice a month I've
like gone out to do some kind of
physical activity with some friends or
whatever or you know like just go on
more walks and you know obviously go
back to the gym and [ __ ] but like I feel
like I don't know I I definitely can
just get more [ __ ] done if I just find
myself in a routine every week
regardless of what the schedule might be
so I just want to like find that one
thing other than the gym where I can
just kind of do something physical for
fun you know where I can like keep
myself healthy and like do some fun
because like you know when I was growing
up I did like a lot of like tennis and
like cricket and footy and stuff like
that so it's like I kind of want to like
go back to that Rhythm because you know
I did tennis for like [ __ ] 10 years
or something and that [ __ ] was so fun
and Incredibly healthy yeah but the
problem is a I don't know uh anyone who
plays tennis and B renting out tennis
courts are [ __ ] pain in the ass in
Tokyo so yeah yeah anything once again
anything that is tough like you know
it's so easy yeah to get any of that
stuff yeah same in Australia you just
[ __ ] rock up and be like oh okay
here's some money give me the court yeah
that's literally is it not that way in
Japan no
because we are in like the like one of
the most dense populated metropolitan
areas in the world right so having a
tennis court is just finding finding a
tennis court is a struggle so they have
them it's just it's for like it's like
the elite like if you if you you want to
have a good tennis court that is
available to you often and you don't
have to book far ahead you need to be in
like some kind of Club yeah and then and
they're not cheap in Tokyo they're
expensive like if you want to do a sport
in Tokyo you need a no you want to do
the sport it is an absolute luxury and
it's expensive and if you don't have
anyone to deal with then it just becomes
like tedious so touching grass here is a
luxury oh yeah oh yeah it is Dude
where's the [ __ ] Concrete Jungle of
Asia dude like it's [ __ ] it's impossible
it's for anything like that but uh yeah
so I kind of want to like I'm just
throwing away tennis being like all
right that's not it I need to find
something else to do so I thought about
like rock climbing and [ __ ] because that
might that's gonna be easier yeah yeah
yeah there's a few really good ones um I
know there's a really big change in
Japan called pump and they have a ton of
locations all around they've won this
really cool it's in Akihabara it's like
I went to that one the one where you can
go to the roof and Overlook Akihabara
while we're climbing yeah yeah that one
was sick it's a really good workout as
well off your arms yeah [ __ ] absolutely
yeah your upper body just gets [ __ ]
yeah dude man I that's that's the one
thing about if you don't go to the like
if you don't work out regular enough and
you're kind of doing it like on and off
it's like you constantly just lose that
progress you made yeah so every single
time you go back to the gym and like do
legs or do arms I did like three days
ago and it's the first time I've done
legs in like two months and I just
couldn't walk for like two days like an
idiot when I go to the toilet and it's
like great
just want to link to the toilet okay
it's just like oh my God he's already
[ __ ] himself I got one of those
exercises how to keep up with every time
you try to reset and beat your ass yeah
yeah do you have any uh goals yeah I
have I have a few goals uh I want to
touch more grass and also less grass at
the same time
explain yourself
explain yourself okay so I I do want to
go on like more small trips and stuff
like that uh but I've kind of set myself
a goal to like go and go in like more
small trips and just not make content
out of it I guess because I realized
this year I did a [ __ ] on this year I
did so much [ __ ] traveling this year
um compared to basically like the rest
of my life but a lot of that was like
filmed a lot of that was like content
yeah and I had this I had this
realization uh when I was uh on my stag
do and uh we were doing uh we were doing
surfing and it was just like I just I
just realized oh my God this is just
like such a pleasant experience to just
do this new activity and not feel like
oh I need to be entertaining I need to
be entertaining or oh I'm learning but
I'm gonna be competing against the boys
in about two hours you know it was it
was it was such a weird mental thing
where I'm just like wait I can just
enjoy yeah enjoy the activities this is
why weekend trips are op just get away
for like a day or two yeah yeah so good
you don't feel stressed you're like I'm
not putting off work it's like two days
yeah sure yeah that's a luxury yeah so
yeah I want to go on I want to go on
more like small trips
um and just not have a pressure to like
film it make content around it just
feels so weird if you're like a normal
person listening what do you mean
YouTube you have to stop yourself from
filming everything what the [ __ ] yeah
well it's it's kind of like it's it's
it's weird right because we've talked
about our Hobbies becoming our jobs and
how that changes your approach to things
right so before you know we had this
like you know anime was my hobby and
then it became my job and then I needed
to change how I approached anime as a
medium because it was my job but also I
still enjoyed it you know and now since
starting trash days now since filming so
much of my life has essentially become
part out of my job even like the
smallest things I've needed to like
change my mentality around right because
you know doing all this cool thing is
traveling around Japan
um you know going to the you know seeing
all these cool places it's great and all
but it's it's still an amazing
experience that I can talk about and
stuff like that but it's not the same as
going there on holiday you know it's
it's not because you're still
technically working there
um and it's it's nice to be able to hit
both you know both boxes to be like I
travel to a cool place and also I was
able to make money out of it as well so
it wasn't a you know it wasn't a
complete write-off in terms of my time
but I I you know I feel like it's to me
I've kind of realized traveling around
and stuff like that traveling for work
traveling for trash taste is very very
different from traveling for holiday as
well so basically I want to take more
holidays
how we arrange this I think all the
trash day shoots we've been we're we're
pretty intense like we yeah we schedule
things very tight and we don't really
leave much room to enjoy the trips but
like whenever I travel with Chris Chris
is very adamant that he wants to do like
we wake up at 11 and we stop filming at
four and it's like and then he's like oh
we have a day off and it's like all
right okay wow all right that's a lot
more magical a lot more fun yeah yeah
but also I get really agitated something
I want to I'm wasting so much time
maybe that's the point Conor maybe
that's the point you know yeah he's not
wasting time he's saving time no no he's
not he's free that's what Chris will say
yeah no I I'm I second the whole like
you know wanting to travel more and [ __ ]
yeah because um I have this app on my
phone called Bean like b-e-e-n yeah it's
basically just like uh I think Google
Maps has it as well but it's basically
like an app where you can track like you
know which parts of the world you've
been to and like stuff like that and I
looked and I was looking at it just you
know randomly a few nights ago and I was
like oh man it says I've I've visited
six percent of the world right and I'm
like [ __ ] that could be higher like I I
want I like I want there's I realize
looking at the map and like where it's
like white it out
he's gamified he's traveling now I'm
just like no I just realized I'm like I
thought in my head I visited a lot of
the world and you know I have you know
on the grander scale of things but it's
like developed worlds yeah yes of course
but like there's also so many parts of
the world that I still haven't been to
that I want to go to yeah and it's like
and again it's like that it's that
mental fight of like the YouTuber brain
kicks in where I go okay should I go and
film it yeah or should I go just to
enjoy it and experience it yeah the real
question is do I want to deduct this on
my taxes or do I not want them to do
this see that is awesome
that's not my YouTuber that's just like
I'm like how can I save money how can I
everything is a tax writer
and [ __ ] the government over yeah quite
frankly if I can do both then hey I'll
take that [ __ ] you know but it's like
yeah that's that's another thing it's
like I kind of want to just like go and
explore more of the world while I still
can yeah because you know God forbid
something might happen you know in our
careers or in our lives or in our health
where you won't be able to do that [ __ ]
anymore so it's like why not take that
opportunity I've always been at the
mentality of like if the opportunity
comes up just [ __ ] take it because
you never know you never know that might
never come again right so it's like just
just take it while you can even if it
sucks at the time it'll be something
cool that you'll remember and think
fondly of and you know utilizing the
next opportunity so that's something I
want to do with like travel uh for next
year and it's like I have like a short
list of countries I've always wanted to
go to where I'm like I think next year
might be the year where I start ticking
those off yeah it's like why not yeah I
mean luckily I I went to Australia for
the first time this year that was a lot
a lot of fun I would definitely want to
go back to Australia yeah I mean
possibly New Zealand as well yeah it's
like I don't exist huh doesn't exist
it's just it doesn't exist it's just an
island off Australia
and I also don't want to travel the
world at the same time kind of lazy
yeah don't play TFT that's not because
because that's the thing I said I want
to touch more grass and I've also I want
to touch less grass as well a part of me
part of me feels like I
where I'm at right now in like and I
suppose with like career and all that
stuff even if I travel to these places I
don't think I would fully appreciate it
yeah I think I would want to wait until
I've actually just slowed down a little
bit Yeah and then I won't then I'll be
able to enjoy it and be more excited
about it I think if I went now and
traveled to all these places it'd be
like when I did it when I was like 15.
like I because my my my dad lived in uh
lived in a different country uh while
working in a different country so we
we're always traveling Europe a lot and
I [ __ ] thought Europe sucks yeah
because I was like 12 and I just want to
play a game boy and now I'm like [ __ ]
man I I should have I should have found
26 and want to play and then people ask
me they're like they're like oh where
have you been in Europe might have been
here here here here like like most of
the European countries I've been to
except for like the Eastern ones and I
was like oh
[ __ ] I don't [ __ ] remember anything
about Malta I don't [ __ ] remember
anything like what if I I just remember
it was like everyone drank a lot well
did you go but that's just because you
went as a kid right yeah yeah but I was
like I was like 15 16 and I could have
done I could have definitely could have
remembered stuff yeah yeah I was like I
don't know like I've been in a ton of
countries as well when I was a kid which
I want to go back to to re-appreciate it
because I don't either don't remember it
fondly or you know you going to you
going somewhere as a kid versus you
going there as an adult like if you
realize adult it's completely because
the biggest difference is you know what
you want to do on like when you go
somewhere yeah I I want to try the Local
Foods I want to just explore the local
areas and just find like some cool
hidden gems because I remember why I
hated traveling as a kid is because we'd
always travel with family or something
and you couldn't choose and you can
choose what you want to do so everyone
would like there would always be that
one person in the group that just wanted
to go to like see like the biggest
monuments or like the big biggest
tourist things to go to and I'm like I
find it's boring as [ __ ] I'm like I do
not like this therefore I do not like
travel so I am just going to understand
going to notch touch grass and then I
realize now that I've done more
traveling it's just like oh if you
actually do [ __ ] that you want to do
instead of just doing going by someone
else's schedule as you can see it's
actually [ __ ] enjoyable yeah you know
I'm also dude I'm guilty of this I don't
know if you guys do this either I'm a
hotel Fiend I stay at my hotel a lot
like when I travel if I'm I'm chilling
I'll stay in the hotel till like 2 p.m
I'll be like I noticed that during the
tour yeah like I'm just I just like to
chill out chill in the room for a bit
because I'm like on my head I'm like I'm
on vacation yeah I'll sleep as long as I
want I want to take my sweet ass time
getting ready yeah I want to nap a ton I
know so [ __ ] much when I'm on
vacation no because I'm like 2 p.m time
for one hour nap yeah for 20 minutes
because I'm when I'm traveling I'm not
the kind of traveler who tries to fill
up their oh [ __ ] schedule as much as
possible you know I like if if I just
find one cool place in the new area I'm
going to even if it's just even if it's
just like one little area that's enough
of me you know I don't need to see like
the entirety of it just just because I'm
a whole I'm on holiday yeah right my
schedule's packed enough as it is off
from my job I just want to go buy my own
schedule see I'm I'm the complete
opposite yeah I've noticed like when I'm
going somewhere especially if it's
somewhere I've never been to I'm like I
don't know when I'm going to be here
next so I want to see as much of it as I
can while I'm here yeah so I'm like
never in my hotel funnily enough I was
like the the only time I've been like
that is when we were touring America
right because right because I remember
like almost every city I was like trying
to do something or meet someone who are
new there and I I just got to see like
quite a lot of America but I feel like
it was weird for me because that was
that wasn't a holiday for me that was
like work so I was like I'm going to
take advantage of this because I'm
traveling America and it's I'm on a work
schedule anyway so I ain't got time to
relax but if I'm actually going on a
holiday holiday
I want to do nothing basically oh yeah I
want to do nothing yeah
I get that man I I really want to go
back to Europe now and just like go
around eat all the good food yeah yeah
you guys had a super good and you never
realized well no because I also like I
remember we traveled a lot because
um my parents
um
you know they wouldn't really buy us
like any like material things it was
always like we'll go on experience yeah
we're going on vacation instead and as a
kid I was like I'd rather have an Xbox
but
um yeah I never got the Xbox
but I remember that when we did travel
Europe because my mum we would do it on
like because we would normally go
camping right so we would drive there
and yeah camps it was like it was all
done on like a really big budget so we'd
never buy food it was always like you
would buy the market cap ingredients and
cook and I'm like [ __ ] man wish I'd
tried some of the yeah but I wouldn't
have appreciated it as well knowing me
yeah I always just ordered pizza anyway
whenever I went anywhere
across Europe every single single time
we ever went to a restaurant was rather
be like pizza
you know what you like and uh because
you're like when you're like 15 you're
like damn they're they're two Foods
pizza and burger
that's it at least okay okay sorry
that's why people are very sorry a lot
of white people would be like no we
don't we don't claim him come get your
hands